foreign
[Music]
19 pandemic saw spectacular advances in
vaccine technology but it also
highlighted the huge importance of
digital Healthcare exchanging clinical
information can be crucial for both
treatments and better patient recovery
it's why digitalization and data sharing
are now seen as key for Public Health
Care Systems
[Music]
and it's the path the European Union is
taking it's just launched a European
health data space that will be gradually
implemented over the coming years but
what is it exactly it's an
interconnected database that aims to
facilitate access to Patients health
information and ensure continuity of
care even when they are in another
European country
the exchange of health information is
currently regulated by existing National
and European legislation the European
health data space promises more
efficient care and better diagnostic
capacity and it should also boost
scientific research enabling European
companies to create more tailored
medicine Health devices and services
finally increased data sharing should
lead to better and more informed policy
making
[Music]
over the last two years several EU
countries have accelerated their use of
digital Health technology Portugal is at
the Forefront of this revolution the
country's Health Ministry is tasked an
I.T authority to carry out this
transition
when it comes to Digital Data what we
want is for this data once it's been
entered into the system to generate
information that actually feeds the
entire system this happens at various
levels in Portugal today we have
clinical data resulting from medical
information that's related to each user
Portugal has almost stopped using paper
prescriptions now around 98 of the
country's hospitals provide digital ones
clinical files are stored online
patients can access the health
information through a website and a
smartphone application where they can
also connect to a doctor for a tele
consultation the same app also allows
patients to reach the ministry of
Health's contact center for General
inquiries in addition to Portuguese
answers are provided in English and sign
language
artificial intelligence is also
harnessing data to help Healthcare
professionals
we're helping in the decision making
process for both doctors and users in
relation to any pathologies that they
might have and that may be more easily
detectable through these artificial
intelligence mechanisms
advances in digital Health are also
underway in Germany with an app system
called Digger at this clinic in botrop
in the northwest of the country doctors
prescribe apps just as they would
medicine to help patients better manage
their health users can download them to
their smartphone tablet or computer the
apps include a range of medical
conditions from cancer to cardiovascular
diseases chronic migraines and
depression
if I think of concrete examples such as
migraine weight loss or tinnitus one can
benefit from receiving support outside
the surgery when it comes to
documentation but also receive help on
what to do when the condition gets worse
so that the patient is not left alone
outside the practices premises so to
speak technical analysts the creation of
a European health data space is set to
revolutionize medicine as we know it
marking a new era of cooperation
European countries are already exploring
ways to harmonize rules and standards
while also making sure patient Health
Data is kept safe
[Music]